we should start with the Wagner Wagner
whatever where you pronounce it so they
are a private military company basically
a mercenary group that Putin has been
funding for a long time in order to
participate in conflicts and train
troops and so on around the world so
that Russia could do things in places
like Syria and various countries in
Africa without actually that being
attributable to the Russian military
yeah and so they've been operating uh as
I say in various different parts of the
world but most prominently in Syria
where they actually
um I did a whole tweet series about this
today they actually uh at one point
found themselves in direct confrontation
with American forces and uh had took
very heavy casualties in that battle but
basically put very simply they're a
private mercenary company that's been uh
fighting in different places around the
world and when Russia invaded Ukraine in
uh March of last year or February of
last year
um in February of last year uh they were
one of the key units that did a lot of
the fighting on the front lines uh and
they because they're very well funded
and they're very well trained and very
experienced they were actually one of
the units that had some of the biggest
successes While most of the Russian
military actually really really
struggled uh and was forced to see
territory that are initially occupied
back to the ukrainians the Wagner group
was one of the group the units that's
been very successful for a number of
reasons one of them is uh they're not
subject to various rules of war and
regulations and so
um they've been able to use very brutal
tactics so uh the other we'll get to
back to that in a second but the other
reason is
they uh had for a long time they were
able to recruit convicts and evgan
progression who's the head of this group
uh he is actually an ex-convict himself
so he would go to these penal colonies
all over Russia into prisons all over
Russia and he would say well you are
here for murder or you were here for
assault or whatever you've got another
10 years on your sentence uh why don't
you come and do six months with me
you'll be paid you'll be well trained
much better trained than if you were in
a regular army uh but much better
equipped and if you do six months with
me you can go home and you get a pardon
so your sentence is completely commuted
as a result which obviously as you can
imagine to some prisoners that would
have been quite appealing and they did
that for a long time
uh and what they did with uh with the
units is basically they use style and
tactics so if you retreat they they just
show you so and he told people when he
was recruiting them at the prison he
would be like no retreat if you're a
tree we're going to shoot you and and
they do this uh they they're one of the
things they're known for is they execute
uh the factors or anyone who surrenders
and then says anything bad about them by
Smashing their head in with a
sledgehammer live on camera and they
publish several of these episodes
um so very brutal very professional
I find it bizarre that somebody who is
as power hungry as Putin who is an
authoritarian
why does he have private armies working
for him well why doesn't he have the
Russian army uh because he can't fund
the Russian well one of the reasons I
explained to you which is he needed them
for operations yeah that he couldn't do
with the full weight of the Russian
State behind it so if you need someone
to go I mean the Americans had and I
don't know if you remember this Scandal
there was a scandal in Iraq when uh some
people from a company called Blackwater
they killed civilians uh in Iraq and
there was a big Scandal the guy had to
sell this company they changed the name
blah blah blah blah blah but but
basically a lot of big companies uh big
countries around the world have been
experimenting with this model where you
have armed mercenaries that are acting
under your direct control but they're
not directly attributable to your to you
so for example
I'm not saying this is exactly why Putin
would have wanted it but remember at the
beginning I mentioned how
um so to to give you a very brief
rundown in Syria the Americans and the
Russians actually coordinated
their movement even though they were on
the opposite sides of that war because
Russia backed Assad and obviously the
Americans didn't but the last thing they
wanted was for like Americans
accidentally to be fighting Russians and
before you know in World War III okay
yeah so in this battle that I told you
about I wish I could remember the name
now but I did a series of Tweets in
which I mentioned it
um today the the Americans said we're
about to engage this Syrian unit are
there any Russian soldiers attached to
it and the Russians were like No And The
Americans were cool so we'll take care
of it then and they killed somewhere I
think two between two and four hundred
Wagner mercenaries because the Russians
basically said well these are not our
guys right so that's obviously the
downside of plausible deniability of
these people being attached to the
Russian military but essentially what it
allows you to do is act in ways around
the world that you couldn't act as a
state because it would be too much of a
transgression for you to do so or there
would be too much bad press or bad
publicity so that's one reason the other
reason is
this is what I was saying to you is if
you have
a bunch of various private armies
emerging in the country uh you're not
necessarily going to be able to rely on
the Russian military all right what if
the Russian military becomes mutualist
for some reason you want a a force or a
set of forces in Putin's case uh that
you control that you can use to defend
yourself to assert your Authority and so
on and precaution was known as Putin's
Chef he was actually a guy who owned
restaurants like he's very closely
connected with Putin apparently until
recently so don't know what's going on
there and nobody does
um and the third thing is I mean this is
an elite unit they're much better
trained much more disciplined much
better equipped than the regular Russian
army are they better paid as well and
they're better paid yeah
because that was a that was one of the
criticisms with the Russian armies that
the pay was awful they weren't properly
trained they didn't have the right
ammunition they didn't have the but
terribly funded so that being the case
he's obviously got many legitimate
grievances against the Russian army
against the
the Russian government but this looks
like an act of lunacy that's